- When you reach our age,
you use the telephone.
We don't make anything at home right now.
The only thing we make is in the toilet.
That's it.
- (laughter)
(whistling and whimsical music)
(popping)
- [Farra] We're on our way
to try some trendy foods.
This is Bubby.
- Hi.
- And Aunt Sydelle.
- Hi!
- Do you guys know what a trendy food is?
- Trendy food, for me, is salad.
I love salad.
- What about for you?
- Chicken noodle soup and some brisket.
- Oh.
- That's trendy food for me.
- Do you know that people put
trendy foods on Instagram?
- You eat it? You eat it on Instagram.
Or you smell it?
- I guess it tells some
people like me what
they're gonna have.
- Exactly.
(exciting music)
- [Mike] The Hong Kong egg
waffles have been around
since the 1960s.
It's actually really popular in Chinatown,
so me and my friends kind of took it,
thought it was really cool.
And we could use it and shape
it into an ice cream cone.
So it's just kind of how it got started.
Sometimes we have lines out
the door and just people
waiting for hours just to get it.
- I guess you wanna get me fat fat.
- I'll try not to.
- I guess so, I guess so.
- I hope it's low-fat.
Mike, low-fat ice cream?
- Far from it, actually.
- Oh!
- I haven't had a waffle,
maybe, in 23 years.
- [Mike] 23 years.
- So I'm anxious.
- What are you talking about?
You have a waffle maker.
- Long time.
- I'm anxious to taste your waffle.
- You have to be very honest.
- Absolutely, I'm a very honest person,
that's how my mom and dad raised us.
Honesty counts and gets you everywhere.
- Never.
- No.
- I cannot wait.
- Me too, me too!
- I'm anxiously waiting, right now.
- So let's get going, enough of the talk.
- Let's get it, let's get it on.
- I'm so excited, this
is absolutely gorgeous.
Mikey, this Eggloo is
beautiful, too beautiful to eat,
but I can't wait to eat it.
- Now, if you don't
talk right, I'm walking
away from you.
- What's wrong with you?
- Just talk regular.
- Am I speaking regular?
I have a chocolate waffle that
looks absolutely scrumptious.
I have a Chocolate Lover ice cream.
Why is it called lover?
Why not plain chocolate, is it special?
Everything in here is chocolate;
sprinkles, I have M & M's.
And can't wait to eat it.
Can I chop into it?
- I have Nutella and
Vanilla on original waffle.
Now, I chose Nutella and
Vanilla thinking Nutella
makes you thinner!
- Why would you think that?
- Because I think people
that are on a diet always
go for Nutella.
- Oh yeah, I can see that.
- But I'll let you know,
guys, if I get thinner
or if I gain a pound from
eating this delicious-looking,
with Oreo cookies that are
diet, probably, in my mind.
A little almonds sprinkled on it.
What do you got?
- I have a green tea waffle
with black raspberry ice cream,
sprinkles, mochi, whipped cream, pochi.
- Let's see how you bite into the waffle!
- Mmmmmm!
- This definitely is for
people who love chocolate.
I can't wait to bite into the waffle.
- [Host] Bite it, bite it.
- I've never had a chocolate waffle.
I'm gonna have an orgasm like this.
- I hope her wish comes true.
Mine is sensational.
- Oh, look how you eat this!
- I'm digging in as I'm speaking to you.
I'm having another.
- Try your waffle.
- Mmmmmm!
- Do you know what?
It's fun eating a waffle this way.
- The only way I could
describe this, really guys,
I'm telling you, this
is fucking delicious.
- Oh my god!
- Really fucking delicious.
And I'm telling you, again.
Fucking delicious.
- I told you I'm the nice one.
- My sister doesn't curse,
but she has orgasms when she eats.
- So do you guys think that
Eggloo is grandma approved?
- [Bubby and Aunt Sydelle
in Unison] Grandma Approved!
- She really wanted to be
not in a trendy restaurant,
she really wanted to be in a porn film.
- (gasps)
- If my granddaughter
was alive 40 years ago
and approached me, I
probably would have said
"That's an honor."
- I would not approach you
to do a porn video for work.